amazing you do great accents okay who
are your favorite people to do these
days
i mean i've always if i really want to
do you know that's a hacky thing but
yeah i've always loved
chris walken
and i'll do christopher walken as a
pigeon for you i'm only going to do it
once okay this is this is one of my
favorite guys by the way yeah
well the story goes this true story that
he he walked in to my
i think it was i can't remember that
randy pearlstein who was a comic and he
told tells the story he's telling on
stage so i'm stealing it from him and he
said
walken walked up to them when i don't
know if it's true but he was he was
drunk and he walked up to them they're
all hanging out and they're all just a
bunch of actors who were in this movie
called search and destroy
and he walks in
and uh they're all like oh [ __ ] chris
we're walking and he goes and he's tall
he bet you that's six three six four and
he goes you guys
you know
what fame is
fame is knowing
you could walk into a room
[ __ ] anyone
in the ass
that's fame
and he walked away
and they're like
what
what happened and then he's dancing with
an actress like this he's doing this and
apparently he'll look over his shoulder
and go the ass
i hope that story is true but it was a
great
story it's true yes yeah you want to see
my impression of christopher walken as a
pigeon
go this is [ __ ] so cocky
i should have my comedy license revoked
this is bull i apologize i'm defaming
it's chris walken as a pigeon
cool
[Laughter]
bread
i got bread on my mind sourdough
cool
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much very impressive very impressed
come on dude that's how that's
high-level action
i just discredited myself
by bitcoin guys that's the point i'm
trying to make so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]